alec baldwin has spoken out on his
involvement in a fatal shooting but did
his body language say more than his
words on october 21st tragedy struck on
the set of the film rust being shot on
location at new mexico's bonanza creek
ranch according to initial reports a gun
fired by baldwin during rehearsal
discharged a live projectile in the
direction of crew members resulting in
the death of cinematographer helena
hutchins and the injury of director joel
souza the shooting has raised a number
of questions from the nature of the
projectile and the gun to the reported
presence of live rounds on the film set
as well as who is ultimately responsible
for the tragedy baldwin also raised new
questions with a new claim during his
december 2nd interview with abc's george
stephanopoulos it wasn't in the script
for the trigger to be pulled
well the trigger wasn't pulled i didn't
pull the trigger so you never pull the
trigger no no no no
of course speech is just one way for a
person to convey information if you know
what you're looking for as such there's
much more to this interview than just
baldwin's words the actor's body
language had a lot to reveal as well to
learn more about alec baldwin's body
language during his abc interview looper
got in touch with body language expert
allison henderson from moving image
consulting what she had to say about
baldwin's behavior during the interview
was quite interesting first and foremost
she mentions that it's important to keep
in mind that baldwin is an actor meaning
there were fewer visual tells to work
off of than there would be for someone
with a different career but just because
he is used to controlling his appearance
in front of a camera doesn't mean that
he's immune from betraying his feelings
through body language starting at the
top henderson says
at the beginning of the interview
baldwin was less comfortable and
exhibited some holding behavior as
evidence she cites the way baldwin sits
while keeping his hands on his knees or
lacing his fingers together but the most
interesting thing about the actor's body
language was his eyes and how he used
them according to the expert the most
striking moments were when mr baldwin
looked george stephanopoulos in the eyes
and when he didn't eye contact henderson
says implies honesty meaning that
baldwin appeared truthful when he
referred to hutchins as a fantastic
person he also appeared truthful when he
recounted his memory of how the gun went
off when i cocked the gun can you see
that can you see that can you see that
and she says and then i let go of the
hammer of the gun and the gun goes off
on the other hand the actor's choice to
drop eye contact when claiming he didn't
observe any safety or security issues on
set as well as his denial that he feels
guilty about the situation indicates
there may be more to the story on those
specific points were costs being cut at
the expense of safety and security
in my opinion no because i did not
observe
any safety or security issues at all in
the time i was there the intention
behind baldwin's big interview seemed to
be to set the record straight but for
many viewers a question remains was he
being honest throughout this interview
according to henderson the answer is a
bit more complex than a simple yes or no
as henderson points out baldwin is an
actor and an extremely seasoned
interview guest as such he was very much
facing this issue on his home turf and
came into the interview prepared the
expert summed up the situation by saying
everyone wants to know if alec is lying
overall there was nothing which stood
out as a major red flag however alec was
also carefully controlling the narrative
by bringing up the feeling on set
multiple references to his family etc he
stuck to his script and his performance
it makes sense that baldwin would want
to maintain control in what was possibly
the most important interview of his
career especially when the first
interview he gave about the subject was
a more volatile affair on october 21st
baldwin shared details about the rust
shooting in a roadside interview with a
group of paparazzi in manchester vermont
in the statements he gave back then he
mentioned his interest in doing what he
could to help improve gun safety on film
sets and mentioned that he'd been in
touch with hutchins family both points
that he repeated in the new interview
with abc he also told the photographers
i've been ordered by the sheriff's
department in santa fe i can't answer
any questions about the investigation i
can't it's an active investigation
baldwin may have shared more information
with his interview but the central
question of who is responsible for the
shooting remains unresolved
someone is responsible
for what happened and i can't say who
that is but i know it's not me
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
the latest breaking news stories are
coming soon subscribe to our youtube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]